after the advent of fire three powerful
souls were claimed by those who came
from the dark first was claimed by Neto
first of the dead
the second went to the witch who felt
the flame and the last went to gwyn lord
of sunlight but there was a fourth soul
discovered afterward and hidden from the
Lord's the Dark Soul
and so the first human was furtive and
kept his soul a secret Lord Gwyn used
his Lord soul to usher in an age of fire
and light pointing for trusted Knights
to defend the realm there was
Dragonslayer Ornstein captain of the
guard hawkeye golf unmatched with the
great bur Chiara and the assassin who
laid waste Quinn's enemies and artorias
the abyss walker' but in time the flame
began to fade the age of the Lord's was
ending and the Dark Age of men was to
begin the four kings were powerful only
their hearts were weak when an evil
serpent dangled the art of lifedrain
before them they were unable to resist
and became pawns of evil the serpent in
question was dark Stoker cothe who
tempted the Kings with the ability to
drain humanity as a reward of their
service this is the art of life train
cars ultimate goal seems to be to return
all humanity to the abyss as every
fragment of humanity is a piece of a
mighty Dark Soul the Knights of New
Londo were transformed into darkwraiths
beings that plagued the citizens of the
city the humanity so that it may be
returned to the abyss the darkwraiths
are the enemies of man and any living
thing that has a solace they were born
in New Londo and that is where they
perished the entire city was AG revised
to contain them for that is uncreated
threat they were
as the first flame continues to fade and
with the darkness looming the deities of
Anor Londo begin to leave the doomed
Kingdom meanwhile the abyss breaks out
again this time in all seal with time
running out Lord Gwyn's final command is
for artorias to halt the inevitable
spread of the abyss and to rescue
princess dusk an old man afraid of the
dark
Lord Gwyn Kindles the first flame of his
own soul artificially extending his age
of fire and so hundreds of years before
the birth of the chosen undead knight
artorias and SIF meet the threat
building in or sill however they do not
succeed
Knight Artorias came to stop this but
such a hero has nerium murmur of dark
without doubt he will this one valueless
overcome by its utter blackness indeed
this may become
strike nine e.r.s somewhat peculiar but
long ago in my home land of oolacile
by a creature from the abyss I won't
have perished then were it not for the
great Knight Artorias intro
I saw little of what transpired your
mind senses were already fled but even
still there was something about artorias
a certain balance of the humors that
quite perfectly fits your semblance
heavens could it be that
so does Dow who rescued me beset by the
abyss the final act of artorias was to
protect his companion he shielded SIF
with the power of his great shield for
his arm was broken and he can no longer
bear the burden
soon after the spread of the abyss was
halted and the deeds of a human were
accredited to artorias the hero who gave
His life to repel the abyss within this
glimpse of the abyss lies a tormented
soul a savior turned demon
hidden from the eyes of his Lord and
comrades as if only for his soul to find
peace at long last a warrior came a hero
of a time long distant yet near the
warrior fought against artorias severing
his bonds with the darkness so that his
honor may remain intact living with the
knowledge that his master saved him with
his last uncorrupted breath watching him
become husk only capable of demented
screams he keeps the ring of artorias
knowing that many will try to traverse
the abyss and
his master's grave imagine what he is
feeling when you come to him years later
for the abyss walker' ring that
debilitated his friend he is trying to
protect you one of you will have to die
because SIF will not give you the
Covenant of artorias willingly
maybe in death he could find his friend
artorias again
you